حسنًا ، دعنا نتحدث عن بعض
أسئلتك حول kovic ونحصل على إجابة عليها من قبل
الدكتورة نيتا أوغدن اليوم ، لذا فهي
أخصائية في الطب
الباطني وأخصائية مناعة ، صباح الخير ، ديبورا كالر تريد
أن تعرف أولئك الذين لم يتم
تطعيمهم وتم تغطيتهم
كم من الوقت يفعلون ذلك  بحاجة إلى الانتظار قبل
الحصول على اللقاح ، صباح الخير ،
صباح الخير ، شكرًا لاستضافتي ،
أعتقد أن هذا سؤال رائع حقًا ، وفي
الواقع إذا كنت قد أصبت بفيروس كورونا
ولم تحصل على اللقاح بعد ،
فلا توجد أي
إرشادات في حد ذاتها حول موعد  احصل على
التطعيم حتى تتمكن من الحصول على اللقاح على
الفور ، ضع في اعتبارك على الرغم من أنه
يجب عليك الانتهاء من
فترة العزل الخاصة بك ويجب ألا تكون أعراضك بعد الآن ،
ولكن إذا تلقيت
الجسم المضاد أحادي النسيلة أثناء
إصابتك بفيروس كوفيد ، فيجب عليك الانتظار 90 يومًا
لأنه قد يكون هناك احتمال.  كن بعض التداخل
بين هذا الدواء
وفعالية اللقاح
kaylee pennington إذا كنت تشاهد أم
نحن نطرح سؤالك الآن و
kayl  كان سؤال إي عن أي
متغيرات جديدة مع لقاحات جديدة
وتكون قادرًا على محاربة
تلك اللقاحات ، لكنها تضع ذلك
في اعتقادي أن هذا مهم جدًا لأنه
بينما نتحدث عن هذه الأيام هو
دلتا البديل والمتغيرات الأخرى في
الأفق وبالتأكيد الشيء المدهش
حول  لقاحات mrna هي أنه يمكن
تعديلها وعند الضرورة ،
يمكن استخدام متغير mrna من البديل في
تلك السيارة في هذه المرحلة ، لا
نرى الحاجة لذلك لدينا
حماية جيدة حقًا ضد حالات الاستشفاء الخطيرة في
المستشفى مع
التيار  اللقاحات ولكن هذا شيء
يجب مراعاته للمستقبل بالتأكيد
نأمل ألا نشهد هذه
المتغيرات حيث يتم تطعيم المزيد من أنحاء العالم حيث
يتم تطعيم المزيد من هذا البلد
لأن هذا هو ما
سيتحكم حقًا في انتشار المتغير هناك
أيضًا المزيد من الحديث في  المجتمع العلمي
حول اللقاحات التي تتناول على نطاق أوسع
بروتين ارتفاع الفيروس التاجي ليس
فقط منطقة واحدة ولكن
حواتم مختلفة ستسمح بمزيد من الاستمرارية
حماية واسعة ضد المتغيرات ، لذلك هذا هو
كل شيء سيحدث في
المستقبل ولكن في هذه المرحلة ليس
بخير ، لذا يسأل ديبي ديغو هل يحتاج الأشخاص
الذين يحصلون على جرعة ثالثة إلى جرعة معززة
مرة أخرى في غضون ثمانية أشهر أخرى ،
إنه سؤال جيد حقًا مرة أخرى أنت
تعرف الكثير  من هذا يعتمد على عدد قليل من
العوامل حيث
يتم تطعيم المزيد من البلدان في العالم ،
قد لا نواجه نفس التهديد من
التباين الذي قد يكون لدينا حماية أكبر
لأنه لن يكون هناك الكثير من
الانتشار المجتمعي ولكن بمجرد التحدث إلى هذه
الجرعة الثالثة  أنت تعرف ما إذا كنت تفكر في
مثل لقاحات الطفولة ، يتم إعطاء الكثير منها
بجرعات متسلسلة على مدار سنوات ،
لذا فإن هذه الجرعة الثالثة ما
نراه في مجلة الطب الجديدة في إنجلترا التي تم
الإبلاغ عنها في متلقي زراعة الأعضاء للأشخاص الذين يعانون من نقص المناعة
ومرة أخرى إس
ائيل هم  لقد أظهر كلاهما أن هذه
الجرعة الثالثة
بشكل فريد منحت حماية أكثر
من اللقاح الأصلي ، لذلك هناك
شيء هنا نعرفه عن الكابينة
التي تحدث في
أن تكون أكثر حماية حقًا ، لذلك قد لا نتمكن من ذلك ،
لكن كل هذا يحدث في
الوقت الفعلي الذي يتعين علينا رؤيته